helped a little birdie told me it is a
world
wildlife day tomorrow now that little
birdie is actually rocky
and she is live at the henderson bird
viewing preserve
she's showing us how we can take a walk
on the wild side
here in vegas off the strip hey rocky
hey jc and mercedes yeah earlier when i
told you guys what was going on today
you were like wait a minute
there's a bird viewing preserve in
henderson it's kind of like a
best kept secret of the town right
absolutely we call it the hidden gem
oh i like that and the oasis of birds
right or
a bird away oasis in the desert for our
local and migratory birds
i like that okay so let's talk about
birding that's what it's called if you
didn't know
um there's a proper checklist though you
need some supplies right to do it right
yeah if you're gonna come out here and
you would like to bird for the day i
would wear lots of sunscreen
bring lots of water with you okay some
sun protection would be good
of course henderson bird preserve
hat check if you've got your own
binoculars definitely bring them but if
you don't we've got loan repairs for you
as well
awesome we also have bird checklist okay
that will show you every bird that's
visited the bird viewing preserve we've
had over 200 species of birds out here
our checklist will show you uh common
birds birds that live here year round
birds that are only here in the summer
or winter so that will
help you determine what you're looking
at today okay and most importantly when
you come
you're going to want to have a lot of
patience because it could take a couple
hours for the birds
that you want to see come out for you
and that's okay because
patience out here is actually peaceful
it is beautiful
out here so it's just a nice walk in
nature really a safe thing to do as well
social distance obviously
so let's talk about what we can what you
guys can see out here right now during
this season in particular
so we've got as i tried to bring you
takers out here at the henderson bird
viewing preserve
we have paved and soft surface trails so
you can walk around and see our nine
different ponds that attract a variety
of birds right now today we've seen some
ruddy ducks some snow geese
we saw some finches earlier as well as
some hummingbirds okay so when i look
into these binoculars you have to tell
me because
obviously i am a rookie here is there a
technique
because right now i'm just like where
it's just like the old
old school cameras right where you need
to to turn the knobs a little bit
okay so that you can focus in on what
you're trying to see
ah interesting okay i'm gonna try and
perfect this by the four o'clock show
but
tell us why las vegas is actually
a hot spot for birding i didn't know
that so this facility is a part of our
water reclamation facility the nine
ponds that we have here
are evaporation ponds so it just
naturally became
a hot spot for birds to come migratory
birds got the rest here water
food and then lots of local birds are
just naturally attracted to the area
so people have been coming over from all
over the world just to come here and the
birds are here then the birders will
come we have
lots of international birders here um
every year as well as a lot of local
birders that really enjoy
i know we can talk about this forever
but i have to wrap you she's hard
wrapping me i'll send it back to you
guys coming up in the four o'clock show
we're going to show you more
of this hot spot of this gym in
henderson thank you rocky
we appreciate it i think off to the far
right i saw some birds that's we gotta
look turn around and go to your far
right there's birds behind you
we'll check back in with rocky in the
four o'clock more bird watching coming
up all right